( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE, PLEASE, THANK YOU.
OH, NO, NO.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME-- OKAY.
NO, I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
WELCOME.
WELCOME TO "THE NIGHTLY SHOW."
I AM YOUR HOST LARRY WILMORE.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE IT.
VERY NICE.
NOW, THAT REALLY MEANS-- THAT
REALLY MEANS A LOT TO ME BUT I
GOTTA GET DOWN TO BUSINESS
HERE BECAUSE LAST NIGHT OUR
COUNTRY GATHERED TOGETHER TO
HEAR FROM ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT BLACK VOICES IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
THANKS FOR WATCHING, EVERYONE.
( APPLAUSE )
( LAUGHTER )
YEAH!
I THOUGHT OUR SHOW LAST NIGHT
WAS BALLER!
ARE YOU JUST GOING TO LEAVE ME
HANGING?
OKAY.
SO WHAT ELSE HAPPENED?
OH, YEAH, THE LEAD-IN TO OUR
SHOW WAS THE PRESIDENT'S STATE
OF THE UNION SPEECH.
BUT WHAT I WANT TO FOCUS ON
TONIGHT IS THE STATE OF OBAMA,
OKAY.
NOW, BEFORE WE GET IN TOO DEEP
ON THIS, I NEED TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT SOMETHING.
I VOTED FOR OBAMA BECAUSE HE'S
BLACK.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
I'M JUST CLEARING IT UP.
PEOPLE ALWAYS ASK ME, "BUT,
LARRY--" THIS IS TRUE.
THIS IS NOT-- THIS IS NOT AN
IMAGINED CONVERSATION, YOU GUYS.
( LAUGHTER )
OH, IT'S TWO LARRYS.
BUT "BUT, LARRY, DO YOU AGREE
WITH OBAMA'S POLICIES?"
AND HERE'S THE TRUTH-- I AGREE
WITH THE POLICY THAT HE'S BLACK.
( APPLAUSE )
AND-- WHICH AND THEN THEY SAY,
"BUT SHOULDN'T YOU VOTE BASED ON
PRINCIPLE?"
THAT'S CORRECT.
AND MY GUIDING PRINCIPLE IS THAT
AS LONG AS HE'S STILL BLACK--
( APPLAUSE )
HE AND I AGREE ON PRINCIPLE.
WE'RE GOOD.
YES.
EXACTLY.
ALL RIGHT.
I JUST WANTED TO LAY THE
GROUNDWORK FOR WHAT'S ABOUT TO
COME, OKAY.
OKAY, BACK TO THE STATE OF THE
UNION.
SO LET'S CHECK IN AND SEE HOW
HE'S DOING.
>> TONIGHT, AFTER A BREAKTHROUGH
YEAR FOR AMERICA, OUR ECONOMY IS
GROWING AND CREATING JOBS AT THE
FASTEST PACE SINCE 1999.
>> Larry: OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
WELL MY FIRST GUT INSTINCT ON ON
THIS YEAH, HE'S STILL BLACK, SO
IT'S ALL GOOD.
"@MIDNIGHT" IS UP NEXT.
GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY!
OH, WE HAVE TO KEEP GOING.
OH, OKAY.
OF COURSE.
WHAT ELSE?
THE ECONOMY IS IN GOOD SHAPE.
OKAY, THAT'S A BONUS.
WHAT ELSE DID THE PRESIDENT HAVE
TO SAY?
>>LAST MONTH WE LAUNCHED A NEW
SPACECRAFT AS PART OF A
RE-ENERGIZED SPACE PROGRAM AND
SEND ASTRONAUTS TO MARS.
AND CONDEMN PERSECUTION OF
WOMEN, MINORITIES, OR PEOPLE WHO
ARE LESBIAN, GAY, TRANSSEXUAL OR
TRANSGENDER
>> Larry: MAN, THOSE ARE
POWERFUL WORDS.
STICKING UP FOR THE L.G.B.T.--
WAIT A MINUTE.
DID YOU SAY WE WERE GOING TO
MARS?
MAN, THAT'S DREAMING BIG.
THAT SOUND LIKE THE OLD OBAMA.
YOU KNOW, ALL AUDACIOUS AND
HOPE-Y.
>> WE'VE SEEN THE FASTEST
ECONOMIC GROWTH IN OVER A
DECADE, OUR DEFICITS CUT BY
TWO-THIRDS, A STOCK MARKET THAT
HAS DOUBLED AND HEALTH CARE
INFLATION AT ITS LOWEST RATE IN
50 YEARS.
( APPLAUSE )
THIS IS GOOD NEWS, PEOPLE.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
( LAUGHTER ).
>> Larry: WAIT, WAIT.
DID WE JUST WINK?
LET'S SEE THAT AGAIN IN SLOW
MOTION.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
WAIT, WAIT A SECOND.
HOLD ON A SECOND.
DOESN'T HE REALIZE HE JUST LOST
AN HISTORIC ELECTION?
I MEAN, BOTH HOUSES BY HISTORIC
MARGINS.
EVEN HIS OWN PARTY WAS DESERTING
HIM.
DOESN'T OBAMA KNOW HE WON'T BE
ABLE TO GET ANYTHING DONE IN HIS
LAST TWO YEARS?
OH!
HE DOESN'T GIVE A ( BLEEP ).
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
NO!
YES!
NO WONDER HE'S THROWING MARS AT
US, MAN.
( BLEEP ).
WHY NOT JUPITER, OBAMA, RIGHT?
JUPITER'S GOT MORE MOVES, MAN.
YES!
OH, MAN. AND IT'S GOT THAT SPOT,
RIGHT?
YOU KNOW, SOME ( BLEEP )
GOING DOWN ON THAT SPOT,
RIGHT? WHERE YOU GOING, LARRY?
TO THE SPOT?
AIN'T NO PARTY LIKE A SPOT PARTY
BECAUSE A SPOT PARTY DON'T STOP.
( APPLAUSE )
UNLESS YOU REVERSE THE LETTERS
AND THEN TECHNICALLY IT DOES
STOP.
OBAMA, HE JUST DOESN'T CARE.
HE DOESN'T CARE WHAT PEOPLE
THINK ANYMORE.
LOOK, CHECK OUT THE AW SNAP
MOMENT OF THE NIGHT.
OKAY?
>> I HAVE NO MORE CAMPAIGNS TO
RUN.
( APPLAUSE )
MY ONLY AGENDA--
( LAUGHTER )
I KNOW BECAUSE I WON BOTH OF
THEM.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: OOOOOOOH!
OH, MAN.
THAT IS AMAZING.
CALM DOWN, MAXINE WATERS.
YOU'RE NOT WATCHING A WORLD STAR
VIDEO.
( LAUGHTER )
THOUGH I HAVE TO AGREE WITH YOU,
MAXINE, BARRY GOT HIS GROOVE
BACK.
>> IF YOU TRULY BELIEVE YOU CAN
WORK FULL TIME AND SUPPORT A
FAMILY ON LESS THAN $15,000 A
YEAR, TRY IT.
IF NOT, VOTE TO GIVE MILLIONS OF
THE
HARDEST WORKING
PEOPLE IN AMERICA A RAISE.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: OH, MY GOD!
THIS IS AMAZING.
HE GOT BACK HIS '04 ORATORY
BUT NOW WITH SIX YEARS OF
EXECUTIVE EXPERIENCE.
THIS IS THE GUY WE'VE BEEN
WAITING FOR, FINALLY!
( APPLAUSE )
SOMEONE WHO IS NOT INTERESTED IN
POLLS OR WHAT PEOPLE THINK.
SOMEONE WHO'S JUST GOING TO HAVE
A VISION FOR SOMETHING AND STICK
TO IT.
HERE'S HE WORST PART-- IN TWO
YEARS HIS LEASE IS UP.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
WELL, LOOK, HE MAY NOT GET
ANYTHING DONE IN THE NEXT TWO
YEARS, BUT AT LEAST HE'LL STILL
BE BLACK.